hello lena dunham morgan with et canada
honor to be here with you okay so listen
you started something we are very happy
you started the whole hot medieval dad
when it comes to andrew scott that's
what he is i mean he was hot priest he's
hot medieval dad soon he'll be hot
something else but it's always hot
what's it like working with him i mean
he's one of my favorite actors so i can
only imagine i was a huge fan for years
and when i reached out to him he was
sort of in the middle of his fleabag
glory run and i couldn't believe he made
the time to talk to me much less come on
to this film and he has become such a
close friend such a trusted collaborator
i just want to work with him over and
over again if he'll have me i love him
okay listen we're hearing a lot of the
screams we know it's for joe joe was
going back there what was it like
working with him
i love joe he's been a friend for years
but i from the moment that i conceived
of this film i knew that it could only
be him in this role so he was another
one where i was just so grateful that he
jumped on board and i don't blame people
for screaming but i want them to know
he's as wonderful inside as you might
find his outsides i love that i also
love that you're walking hand-in-hand
with your husband you guys are adorable
what's it like having his support here
tonight well he's not just supporting me
he's celebrating too because he um
created the soundtrack for the film
carter burwell did our score and my
husband louis felber and his producing
partner matt alchin did our soundtrack
and so he's also here to celebrate what
he does but i'm really lucky that i have
a husband who only ever lets me shine
and i think for a long time i didn't
even know how to do that for myself so i
feel really lucky in many many ways and
if it can happen to me it can happen to
anyone oh my god i love that listen what
a great night for you congratulations
amazing cass i'm really excited
thank you
you